je m'appelle lui si j'ai 26 ans je suis
séropositive et aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler de ma vie avec le vih
[Musique]
a priori j'ai été contaminées par voie
sexuelle
c'était certainement un partenaire d'un
soir une bêtise
au début ça a changé mon rapport au
corps mon rapport aux autres j'ai dû
prendre des médicaments tous les jours
je me suis demandé ce que ça allait me
faire sur le long terme ça a changé mon
rapport à ma santé dès qu'il y avait un
petit truc qui allaient page mais
c'était grâce si c'était pas grave si
c'était lié à ça ou pas ça va faire un
choc autour de moi il ya des gens qui
l'ont pris à mes soeurs l'ont mal pris
mais tout le monde a su garder un peu la
mesure des choses et quand on explique
en fait correctement ce qui se passe ou
ce qui va se passer
les gens comprennent rapidement que
c'est pas que je vais pas tomber
gravement malade et que je vais pas
mourir et que mon espérance de vie va
pas être réduite de 40 ans et donc les
gens comprennent et this bon ça c'est
grave c'est quelque chose c'est
important mais c'est pas la fin du monde
[Musique]
j'ai passé l'âge les jamais eu et a
priori je n'aurais jamais si tout va
bien le sida c'est quand le vih dépasse
un certain seuil justement quand la
charge virale devient de trop importante
et donc qui permet un affaiblissement du
système immunitaire qui permet à
d'autres maladies de s'installer qui
s'appelle les maladies opportunistes et
c'est ça qu'on appelle le stade sida mon
traitement moi c'est trois pilules à
prendre toutes les 24 heures ce que ça
fait c'est que ça diminue la charge
virale du donc du vih dans le corps qui
fait que d'une part il est assez peu
présents donc il n'a pas d'impact sur
mon organisme et d'autre part il est
pile peut pas être transmis c'est ce
qu'on appelle la charge est indétectable
au début j'avais peur de contaminer
l'autre et
et on devait garder le préservatif le
premier petit copain que j'ai eu après
l'avoir appris on est resté deux ans
ensemble on n'a jamais arrêté de
préservatifs et mais à part ça on n'y a
rien qu'on pouvait pas faire en fait
mais enfin lui il était assez inquiète
donc il avait voulu venir un rendez vous
avec mon médecin pour savoir exactement
est ce qu'on peut faire certaines choses
pas dans le sexe oral est ce que c'est
plus contaminant est ce qu'il ya des
risques et le médecin danesi non parce
que comme la charge virale est
indétectable justement il ya aucun
risque de transmission
donc en fait on peut tout faire et
actuellement avec mon nouveau partenaire
avec qui je suis depuis un petit bout de
temps ici depuis deux ans on a carrément
pu arrêter le préservatif
donc on a même plus ce truc là qui nous
rappelle que d'un que ya le vih en fait
[Musique]
le dépistage est donc connaître son
statut qu'ils soient négatifs ou
positifs c'est c'est savoir si on
protège l'autre et soi même si on est
positif on peut commencer un traitement
on peut rire du sahara charge virale et
donc on peut ne pas transmettre le virus
et si on est des gatti fonds peut le
rester surtout il ya des gens qui ont
donné littéralement leur vie pour que
nous on se convainc tamines plus pour
que l'épidémie cesse et oui derrière fin
on est encore trop nombreux à pas faire
attention ne va pas leur faire honneur
en fait pendant un moment je me suis
senti très coupable d'avoir réussi à me
faire contaminer alors que
avait prévenu quand même j'étais enfant
mais j'avais vu des campagnes j'avais vu
des affiches jamais vu des reportages et
j'avais quand même je suis a fait ce
choix inconscient ou pas de ne pas faire
attention
donc je me suis sentie coupable de deux
doigts de mettre les c'est d'avoir été
inconsciente insouciante parce que enfin
on peut pas dire qu on nous prévient pas
quoi juste qu'on écoute pas